it's webon time ladies and gentlemen
John how are you spider first more K the
son man Cody Johnson owns Valentine's
Day now the bondage is whips oh my God
have we hit the 15 to 20 second Mark yet
cuz that's what's required are you
excited to talk about Ezekiel Sims is he
in this that's what I read on Twitter
Spider-Man number 30 is Ezekiel Sims as
invented by J Michael shinski
illustrated by John meter Junior ever
felt like your browser is as flat as the
deepest understanding of marine biology
welcome aboard the Opera GX not your
average browser teaming up with jmv
Opera GX allows you to dive into the
world of the boys customiz your browser
themes colors and even sounds just like
homelanders laser eyes this modded look
is dazzling exclusive to oper GX users
there's V the vot International's inor
social platform it's for fans catch up
with characters like Marie and Emma as
they climb the rankings of God you feel
like Starlight got you through the
darkness of boring browsers head to the
GX store flip your entire browser
universe and be the beacon of coup and
if you want to have more power over your
setup than Andre Anderson there's a
social media sidebar for everything else
Twitter Tik Tok Instagram and more vots
approved of course switching over
doesn't need super strength no no import
bookmarks history and even extensions in
a Flash faster than a train on a good
day thanks to oper GX for sponsoring
this video level up your browsing game
folks download oper GX and oh yeah don't
miss gen V on Prime
video hey come on get your stuff let's
go right away oh Sydney
Sweeney
waa that was a cool shot practical
Spider-Man
damn damn this like upgrade
yeah she got pruned from the web of
life this going to be a fourstar picture
a week ago I spent my life racing
against time I'm going to help you out
today okay try people who are running
out of
it one moment
changed
everything oh my god spider baby is that
M Parker is that little M Parker think
it was is that Peter Parker I don't
understand what's happening I've been
having
Vision I knew he was going to die
preck good shot there's some good shots
in there New York City is a whole new
level of crazy these days do that again
he's shoeless it might be Ezekiel
Sims
New York City is a whole new level of
crazy these days final spider
destination get off the train that man's
trying to kill you why who are you what
is going
on oh my God I can see the future Sydney
Sweeny and glasses me likey what the
hell she didn't see that coming that's
not how it works it's not how being
psychic works I've seen that man before
so who is he Ezekiel
Sims with my mom when she was
researching spiders right before she
died just toing through that little web
you live in my building you're the
paramedic yeah you almost ran me
over you don't think this is weird how
we're all connected I do I think it's
weird honestly like the least weird
thing that's happened all
day I have no idea what those girls have
come can see into the future
he's trying to change what happen hell
yeah man jul get down this a cool
Direction some of
this it's got that Sony cheese I love
was almost so
different if you
want you have to trust
me get ready I they're in New York and
Spider-Man's actually swinging
around
you're showing off maybe a
little I'm very excited do you know
Spider-Man supped to play taste in New
York and this movie knows it yeah that
feels so like New York Webhead it does
it's got that for sure look at the jness
I'm so excited vibrating off of coy
right now how many Spider-Man leave New
York immediately to go to Europe or to
go to space this has some flavor of New
York far from hope all of the homecoming
he was in the suburbs and then and in no
way home they like took him away from
New York so he could have emotional
beats adjacent that was great John
please oh it's more than time in in
honesty this does look really fun and
it's been a minute since we've had one
of these Sony trailers it feels like
forever ago we were watching the Craven
trailer and uh this does like you said
have that uh kind of cheesy but also
intriguing quality this feels tangible
this feels like a movie out of a
different time a little bit and and
oddly enough is as much as people dog
Sony I do think that they have like an
oddly uh I don't know invigorated
version of this universe they keep you
know proliferating for us and uh I as
much as I think that that is in some
ways disjointed the disjointedness is
also like part of the style that has
become endearing excited to see all
these different characters team up could
be very silly but also seems like it's
probably going to give you some of the
Spider-Man stuff that's become like
complicated out of existence lately so
I'm I'm cautiously optimistic this has
that B movie cheese that I love from
Sony especially in their trailers the
cast looks reasonably fine one thing
that I was surprised by there actually
seems like there's a lot of cool Purpose
with a lot of their uh action shot they
shot the movie it doesn't look like a
lock off frame they like those hoad
shots I think a lot of the other Sony
Spider-Man movies kind of look like
they're all shot by the same person and
this feels like it was shot by someone
with some intentional Vision Dakota
Johnson's delivery was not my favorite
in the trailer but I've seen her in a
lot of things that I have really really
really enjoyed her in it's just a
trailer so I'm just going to wait for
the actual movie itself it's not like
the Sony Spiderman movies give out the
best performances out of great actors
all the time anyway we'll see how this
goes but yeah I mean it looks like uh a
little bit Whimsical I like the look of
the Spiderwoman outfit it's cdy Sweeney
man I love her in euphoria think I've
ever seen her in and she's really
talented and she's hot as hell too so
you get the combination of talent and
hotness and you got my ticket baby just
delaying the time so Koy can ramble wait
who's Adam Scott playing I think he's
Peter Parker I think he's so excited I
think I don't think he's Peter Parker I
think he's gonna be her universe as
Peter Parker and I think I think the web
of life is keeping her protecting May
Parker from existence I thought there
was baby Peter Parker in this he's got a
baby par sure he's not Ben Parker uncle
that'd be Ben Parker I mean she is old
in the comics but they're using the
young version of who Ezekiel Sims
Ezekiel Sims is a professor uh
professorial element of Peter Parker's
life that is introduced an Amazing
Spider-Man number 30 he's a man who
introduces the concept of the spider
totem he's got this great concept of
there is an element of the people that
get bit by the spider that is uh
predetermined so they have this totem
that's why Spider-Man has a lot of
animal themed villains you got scorpion
you got vulture all those things is
because the spider totem is an element
that draws this in so did the spider
bite Peter Parker giving him the powers
or did the radiation uh basically allow
that to go through because Spider-Man
Peter Parker was already predestined to
fit with that radiation like chicken egg
power cause so uh Ezekiel Sims is this
man who kind of guides him through the
spider totem concept which is uh this
idea that leads to the spider verse that
leads to the web of life so my concept
is that we see obviously she's Tethered
to the Web of Life she can see things
she's you know Deon Sawa and Final
Destination but I think what ends up
happening is her universe's Spider-Man
uh is meant to have this baby who's May
Mayday Parker who was very important
later on and that baby I think in the
trailer is going to be young Mayday and
that one little quick shot is is him I
believe is Peter Parker but we've got
like Aran
ar ar who's another Spiderwoman who we
see with the the legs coming out who is
another version of a future um
Spider-Man Spiderwoman and then
obviously we have a Spiderwoman herself
played by Sydney Sweeney who's another
universes so I think we'll we'll see a
bit of multiversal stuff that will tie
to the web of life and that's basically
going to be Dakota Johnson's job I
wouldn't be surprised if at some point
we see in the future like you know old
in the chair so we can kind of see what
all happens but I think by the end of
this I me obviously got to age you up
but uh I think by the end of this we see
that the web of life is interconnected
and this might I don't know if it's
going to tie into things going from 2D
to 3D from animated to live action but
they could glimpse into some of that
here uh and I'm wondering if Ezekiel
Sims is going to be a Twist like if he's
the bad spider uh it does look like
they're playing with the idea that he
he's not all there I'm wondering if
they'll make it Kane maybe they'll make
it like you know another Peter Parker
they could play with the idea of instead
of a clone like a mutilated Peter from
another Multiverse I don't know if
they'll deal with clones in here but
there's a lot of potential to tie into
the lore of Spider-Man that wouldn't get
told another thing and what I liked most
was it's shot like a Spider-Man movie
like they give you some angles and some
web swinging and some New York which I
was so excited about but it feels like
and this is a compliment The Amazing
Spider-Man cinematography where it felt
like you were thrust into the world as
opposed to watching the world and I
really dug that yeah
as a uh Sony Marvel movie like guy I
love that they have cornered the market
on the 2000s like I love that like 2000s
movies they used to like they used to
play more like 2000s movies were like
let's just see when comic movies would
come out in the 2000s it was like let's
see what insane angles we can get away
with because it's a comic movie this
feels like they're like let's dance but
we have
technology so I mean that looked like a
lot of fun to me it looked like you know
we're getting a beautiful array of the
different spider women tone and it could
allow for some really fun tie-ins to
things in the future if this does well
there's certain women we got mattye
Franklin Cassandra Webb and Julia
Carpenter spiderwomen so they're all
different spider women I mean I mean you
know Cassandra Webb is is mad Madam web
but in the comics Madam web is actually
also invented by John Jr like Ezekiel
Sims but much later on like 30 years
later big career John J she is a usually
an older character that is portrayed as
like a soothsayer kind of the blind
soothsayer element of Mythology sitting
in the web like perceiving all bit of a
profit Spider-Man goes to her in the
Animated Series very famously a lot of
people know her from the Animated Series
but in the newer comics in the last 20
years they've deaged her she's a bit
more of a spy she's a little more
playful they're going with that version
clearly with Dakota Johnson uh Maddie
Franklin is the niece of J Jonah Jameson
it'd be really fun if they use the Nexus
being concept and they've got JK Simmons
in this as her uncle because she's like
the wealthy niece that uses like you
know the the the connections through
that to kind of become a different
Spiderwoman she's the woman with the uh
The Superior Spider-Man esque arms uh
she was a short-lived run I think John
burn invented her a very iconic fixture
of comic books and she's a lot of fun
but a very different a little more sassy
version of a Spiderwoman uh and then
Julia Carpenter is like your classic
injected with a mix of like plants and
Spider Venom like that more scientific
like a nefarious plot to Creator
Spiderwoman and I think that's going to
be our our Sydney Sweeney with the black
and white suit we see very briefly and
basically she is your agent type like
she's gonna be more of your your cop on
the edge uh so it's it's giving us uh
the industrialist the Spy the soothsayer
so they're all doing different elements
in this case um I believe all of them
are going to be from Earth 616 which in
the comic books is our is our main our
sacred timeline I'm wondering if they're
going to make it so the Sony designation
is a different number it wouldn't
surprise me if in my opinion the MCU is
Earth 19999 but Kevin feige calls it 616
those the comic should be separate
universes but I'm wondering if they'll
establish a Sony universe number
designation they'll all be from that one
universe and it' be interesting to see
if Ezekiel is from a different one or if
he's from a universe that might tie into
beyond the spiderverse or if they'll do
something where they acknowledge the
Marvel 616 and a Spider-Man there but I
maintain even if we have him as Ben
Parker I think we're going to find out
that maybe he is a Peter Parker clone
Peter Parker brother Peter something's
going to tie into Peter where it's going
to be a reveal I think maybe he goes by
his middle name Peter Benjamin Parker is
Peter Parker's name um so either way I
think that's May Parker dude he could
become Ben Riley somewhere down if if he
if he changes his name to Riley at any
point in this the amount of I will
lose they're going to have to have a
HazMat
team gon to be so excited all over the
Ben Riley's my boy and there's gonna be
a lot of uh yeah this is this to me
is is it's going to be the Easter eggs
that you want out of these movies but
they're so specifically Niche for people
like me that it won't Ru continuity this
feels like they made it for Spider-Man
fans to just go like oh my God they did
that and we're never going to worry
about it over here and I for that I
thank them well I'm just excited for a
self-serious Spider-Man Sony movie you
know that's all I care about it's all I
care about right now and uh in a day and
age where uh you know we just had a
female Le comic book movie that is not
doing that great at the box office I
hope this skyrockets and dominates and
I'm going to say I like it in advance
right
now get ahead of it get ahead of the
curb I've already decided I've
already I love it favorite one I think
it kept its release date right February
all right let's hope so dude we need
February we need a movie in 2024 to
happen Al righty guys well what did you
think about the trailer are you excited
for it are you excited as this guy over
here Dakota Johnson owns Valentine's Day
now the bond just
webs true 50 Shades of webs 50 stades of
webs the webs are
[Music]
gray